hello i'm prathee kanari security
architect for ibm cloud
today we are going to look at ibm cloud
data shield and how it enables you to
protect your containerized applications
data in years or in memory
we are going to see this in action with
help of a demo application we built
called cloudfund
but first let's talk about data
protection
we believe it requires protection of
data throughout its lifecycle in transit
at rest and also in use
and we have been on a mission to address
that with confidential computing which
protects data in use by performing
computation in a hardware-based trusted
execution environment
and datashield is a deployment time tool
that helps you adopt confidential
computing on x86 platforms specifically
intel software guard extensions with no
code changes
let's see how this works
cloud fund is a python app we built for
this demo
and yes with data shield powered by
photonics runtime encryption
in addition to cc plus plus we also
support java python and rust runtimes on
sgx
cloudfond is a containerized application
running on kubernetes cloudfont is a
typical three-tier application with a ui
backend api and a database
for the database we are using
confidential database service from our
portfolio called hyper protect mongodb
so it is very secure
for this demo let's focus on the threat
factors that come at the backend api
layer and how a privileged user
infrastructure admin for example with no
access to database can steal sensitive
data from the backend api's memory
as a narrative element for this demo we
are using cloudfont to donate money to a
charity
let's see how it works
so i open the cloudfone
application in my browser i click donate
now
here i'm giving the details and
importantly i'm giving my personal
information and also the credit card
number
and get expiration date
and the cvv
and click submit
now the data goes to the backend api
now let's see how a privileged user
attack can play out
here i'm logged into the server as a
privileged user
so have my terminal open i'm trying to
log into the workload in question
once i'm in there let's find the
processing question the python app i was
talking about
once i have that let's find the pid
once i have that let's memory dump it
now let's look for strings in the memory
dump
that's a lot of data let's search for
my name
as you can see this is a problem this
application is vulnerable to privileged
user attacks targeting its memory
contents
now let's see how you can protect your
applications data and use with data
shield
let's take a look at data shield's
documentation
you start your journey in the getting
started page one of the first things you
do is you have the right cluster
the right worker nerd
and you run couple commands for
prerequisites
and you install datashield through this
hum chart
replace these values with the chart name
your email id account id and english sub
domain
and you get your dedicated single turned
instance of data shield running natively
on your cluster
now let's look at the ui
you log into the ui using im token
once you are in there you can manage
your worker nodes and look at their
attestation reports
you can create apps
and bills for your pipelines
you can create tasks so you can approve
or deny a build
and the user section you can add your
teammates
and you can manage them
now let's go back to the application and
see how easy it is to convert your
application from its current state to
runtime memory encrypted counterpart
since datashield is a deployment time
tool you don't have to make any changes
to occur
you make this api call from your ci cd
pipeline prior to deployment of your
application
replace these values here with your
application container name and the new
name for the new sgx capable image we
create for you
when you call this api since it give
data shield read write privileges to
your container registry at installation
data shell pulls the current image
converts and packages to sgx capable
counterpart and pushes the new image
back to your registry
now you continue with your cd process
and deploy your new runtime memory
encrypted backend api
let's look at the changes you make to
the ammo real quick
as you can see all we need is couple of
volume mounts for hdx drivers
you can find an example of a yaml in our
documentation
let's go ahead and deploy this new
backend api and perform the same steps
as earlier
i want my terminal
i'm deploying the new api
once it's up let's go to the browser
under the same steps as before
i'm in the cloud fund i'm donating
to cloudfone i gave my name my address
my telephone number
my credit card number
the expiration date and the cvv
and click submit
now let's go back to the terminal again
and try to scrape for text in the memory
dump of this process
here i am in the worker node
i'm trying to search for the process
here and the pid
once i have the pid let's memory dump
the process
once you memory dump it let's scan for
plain text in this memory
dump and to make it easier let's give a
name
but you see nothing because the memory
is encrypted
there you have it
in about five minutes you go from an
application that is vulnerable to a
runtime memory encrypted counterpart
datasheet helps you and your team do
what you do best developing stellar apps
datashield takes the burden off from the
development to the deployment time and
helps you protect your sensitive data in
memory without any code changes
please give ibm cloud datasheet a try
and reach out if you have any questions
thank you
you